king shark is one of the weirdest
characters in the dc universe
and now thanks to the suicide squad he's
one of the most beloved too
but who is this furious fish and just
what keeps him swimming
this is dc's king shark explained you're
gonna need a bigger boat
you'd probably be forgiven for thinking
that king shark started out as an
aquaman villain
after all it makes sense that dc's most
notorious aquatic villain would be the
nemesis of dc's most famous aquatic hero
right
however although king shark would face
off with the king of atlantis in later
issues this isn't the case
he actually made his comic book debut as
an adversary of the lesser known hero
superboy
in the 1994 comic superboy vol 4 number
zero
king shark is introduced in the shadows
under the name of
nanawe he subsequently stirs up trouble
in the series ninth issue
in which he breaks out of prison has a
grisly reunion with his mother and
attempts to gobble up surfers at the
beach
predictably superboy himself puts a stop
to all this
this cemented a long-standing rivalry
between this original version of king
shark and superboy
they would continue to face off across
the issues that followed including one
storyline that sees king shark squaring
off against his foe
as a member of the suicide squad in the
years that followed king shark battled a
wide array of dc comics mainstays
including aquaman himself
he also became a member of the central
ensemble in a number of suicide squad
storylines but his earliest stories are
very much confined to super boy's comics
where he first established himself as a
comic book baddie with
serious teeth some comic book characters
have a very specific origin story
one that is rarely altered even over the
course of many decades
others however take a little more time
to have their origins filled out this is
true of king shark who was initially
presumed in his earliest superboy
appearances to be either a human being
who had turned into a shark-like
creature
or a highly evolved form of shark this
carried over into subsequent king shark
appearances but it wouldn't remain that
way for long
future comic book story lines made clear
that king shark was neither mutant nor
amped up shark in aquaman sword of
atlantis number 40 king shark is
confirmed to be the son
of a shark god an idea that had been
introduced and dismissed in his original
superboy appearance
this didn't just clear up where this
super villain came from though it also
provided a nice dose of humor in
subsequent adventures
juxtaposing king shark's status of
royalty with his low-life thuggery in
the suicide squad
meanwhile the character's royal ancestry
has played a part in many of his
non-comic book appearances such as
forming the basis for his backstory on
the harley quinn animated series
everyone knows that sharks don't talk
this simple fact is ignored by king
shark however who usually displays at
least to some level of speech
however the various comic and media
incarnations of king shark have given
him
varying degrees of eloquence over the
years in the early superboy comics he
doesn't talk at all
subsequent comic book appearances had
king shark be capable enough of talking
that he could make pointed comments and
grim jokes
but later on he was again reduced to a
more feral creature with a limited
ability to speak
modern media has taken a similarly fluid
approach to king shark's speech patterns
for example the suicide squad's version
of the character seems unable to say
much other than a few choice words other
incarnations of the character
like that seen on the harley quinn
animated series are about on par with an
average human being
even displaying more emotional
sensitivity than many of the people
around him
we put the profile up and we're not
getting any bites is that a shark
joke if so it's
very funny the flexibility of this
quality in king shark was certainly a
total accident
but it actually has its advantages as it
allows a greater degree of freedom for
individual
storytellers to put their stamp on the
character
the secret six were a d-list group in
the dc comics pantheon until acclaimed
writer gail simone breathed
new life into them with her 2006
iteration of the team
this group's ever-shifting roster
eventually included none other than king
shark who like the others were included
in the team as something of a last
resort
once her original plan to utilize a-list
dc comics super villains fell through
simone shifted over to the lesser-known
bad guys simone once explained
it started as a joke we should just pick
the crappiest villains that no one in
their right mind would want
so i picked a bunch of losers too low to
even be
on the suicide squad though not on the
initial secret 6 lineup it wasn't long
before king shark became a prominent
part of the group
appearing in 15 separate issues of
secret six
as simone herself as noted this more
lovable take on king shark has served as
inspiration for many subsequent versions
of the character
when you're making a cw tv show you have
to be aware that your storytelling
opportunities might be limited by your
budgetary restrictions
even the best major broadcast tv shows
are typically made on shoestring budgets
and for a superhero series that sadly
rules out a number of the flashier more
cgi heavy villains out there
but that hasn't stopped the flash from
delivering some grandiose and expensive
looking foes during its time on the air
including the unexpected live-action
debut of king shark
brought to life through full cgi king
shark was an
unexpected presence for a major
broadcast network program
but there he was right in the final
moments of a season 2 episode
the character would go on to have a
recurring presence on the flash that has
extended well beyond mere cameos
in fact king shark has become enough of
a staple on the show to have episodes
largely revolving around his
own storylines such as the season 5
episode king shark vs gorilla grodd
king shark may not have been much of a
flash adversary in the comics but he
nonetheless cemented himself
as a fan favorite villain for the cw's
take on the super fast superhero
kingshark's presence in the virtual
world began with his debut
in dc universe online before making a
couple of appearances in the more
family-friendly
titles lego batman 3 beyond gotham and
lego dc super villains
in all these instances king shark's
presence was less of a reflection on how
popular the character himself was
and more of an attempt to make sure all
three titles had as comprehensive a
library of dc comics characters as
possible
king shark's most prominent video game
appearance has yet to arrive however
the upcoming game suicide squad kill the
justice league will finally feature the
character in a capacity beyond that of a
glorified cameo
in this game king shark will serve as
one of the game's four leads alongside
mainstays from the comic book version of
the suicide squad including harley quinn
captain boomerang and deadshot voiced by
samoa joe
the trailer for the game establishes
king shark as a more considerate soul
with an extensive vocabulary as well as
the ability to chomp down enemies in a
single gulp
in recent years king shark has become a
prominent fixture in a number of
animated dc comics properties
while his presence in dc superhero girls
demonstrated that the character can work
in family-friendly animated properties
kingshark has had a notable animated
presence on shows aimed at adults
for instance king shark appears in the
extremely violent direct-to-video movie
batman assault on arkham
in which he is voiced by john dimaggio
who would reprise the role in justice
league dark
apocalypse war though these versions of
king shark share a voice actor they're
quite different in personality with the
version in apocalypse war having his
dialogue largely
limited to this king shark is a shark
but the most popular animated
incarnation of king shark was featured
in the recent harley quinn series
voiced by ron funches this version of
king shark reimagines the underwater
villain as a relaxed tech savvy
everyman first introduced in the show to
help harley quinn with an online profile
meant to attract potential foes
king shark ends up becoming a prominent
part of harley's team
this version of the character became so
popular that the suicide squad director
james gunn even gave it a shout out on
twitter
speaking about the design inspiration
for his own take on kingshark
gunn said i love king shark's design and
the harley quinn show
and ron funch's version the 2016
suicide squad movie featured plenty of
leading lights from the dc comics mythos
a man-sized crocodile who eats people a
lady who traps the souls of her victims
in her sword
and of course slipknot the man who can
climb
anything okay so it wasn't a great movie
but that weird lineup would have been
even more peculiar had it included king
shark
as the movie's writer director david
ayer originally intended
ayer himself revealed this in a twitter
video when a fan asked if there were any
comic book characters he wanted to
include in the film but couldn't
king shark turned out to be one of those
figures of course this isn't all that
surprising considering the character has
been a regular member of the comic book
incarnation of the team
so why didn't he get into the original
suicide squad movie
well as ayer said we realized it would
take a lot of work
a lot of cg work i wasn't comfortable
going with a fully cg
character hoping to keep the film as
practically realized as possible king
shark was left behind for the suicide
squad's
silver screen debut ayer also revealed
that the exclusion of king shark allowed
for the inclusion of killer croc
who was realized through makeup effects
rather than cgi
james gunn has always been a proponent
of motion capture technology in his
comic book movies
usually he has a cg character
represented on set by one actor before
another takes on voice over duties in
post-production
this is a method gun utilized for the
roles of groot and rocket raccoon in his
two guardians of the galaxy movies with
the latter
character being portrayed on set by sean
gunn before being voiced by bradley
cooper
gunn has also returned to this curious
method of casting for the character of
king shark in the suicide squad for this
incarnation of the character gunn had
the character represented on set by
another of gunn's regular collaborators
steve agee it was made clear early on
that aeg wouldn't be providing the voice
for the character however
since he was only credited as an onset
actor in the dc
fandom 2020 materials for the suicide
squad although he wasn't to voice king
shark himself
aeg still scored an on-screen role in
the suicide squad in the form of amanda
waller's right hand man
john economos in november 2020 the
internet was thrown into a fury of
speculation when james gunn announced
that he would be reuniting with his
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 cast
member sylvester stallone for a voice
over role in the suicide squad
and it wasn't long before the internet
found out who rocky balboa would be
playing in the dc universe
the day the first suicide squad trailer
dropped it was confirmed that stallone
would be lending his distinctive voice
to the character of king shark
the news came on the heels of
speculation not only over who stallone
would be playing but also
who could be voicing king shark with
frequent gun collaborator michael rooker
being a name
previously rumored to provide the
character's voice work all that
speculation was for naught however as
gunn had apparently long imagined
stallone inhabiting this fishy role
in fact in the wake of the announcement
gunn revealed on twitter that he wrote
king sharks specifically forced alone
turns out there was nobody more perfect
for the role of king shark than this
icon of 1980s cinema check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one